what an honor and inspiration I look
down at these filmmakers and I see the
next stage the next generation that has
afforded the responsibility to push in
us his nostalgia
they said do you want to come in and
give this war and I said absolutely I'm
an act I want to meet them first so here
we are the last category of the night
a narrative film which is my personal
favorite narrative films are all about
the story tonight we are here to
recognize three of the best young
storytellers in the world with over 249
entries this year here are the top 3
narrative films above the sea Keola
rasuluh from Columbia University in New
York is a talk suspenseful drama about a
prostitute in 1930 Shanghai who was
pushed to revenge after the murder of a
young girl adore God by Yulin Liu from
New York University is a tender
beautifully observed film about the love
and longing little girl feels for her
mother who was abandoned who has
abandoned the family and interstate my
camille stowage from the American Film
Institute in California and this
compelling drama a driving instructor
puts himself in jeopardy and rediscovers
the American dream after helping a young
undocumented immigrant get her papers